well it's midterm time again in America
so what's at stake and why do these
elections matter more than most
[Music]
right across America all the predictable
issues are there with the Republicans
and the Democrats bitterly divided
there's the gun debate the economy crime
immigration climate change education and
in particular this election abortion
abortion is the most profound and
explosive of issues a decision earlier
this year by the Supreme Court put
abortion rights into the hands of each
individual State and lawmakers there
here in California there's a ballot
measure to allow voters to decide
whether to enshrine the right to choose
abortion into this state's Constitution
the court got row right nearly 50 years
ago and I believe Congress should codify
a roe once and for all
it's typical for a sitting president's
party to lose seats in the midterms but
the Democrats are Keen to book that
Trend and they're hoping to do so by
focusing on abortion in the immediate
aftermath of abortion being revoked as a
constitutional right polls were strong
for the Democrats but since then the Gap
has narrowed but these midterm elections
are also about something much more
fundamental the future of Democracy in
America is on the line now that may
sound dramatic but in these bitterly
divided United States people are
genuinely rattled it is all about this
man yes Donald Trump still commands huge
power Across America and yes he still
claims without any evidence that he beat
Joe Biden two years ago I ran twice I
won twice I did much better the second
time
and people believe him so how many of
you here believe
the Donald Trump
should have won or did win the last
election he absolutely did win
you all think the election was stolen by
Biden
these elections will be a measure of
just how relevant Trump is many of his
election denying allies are running for
various positions of power and authority
some of them if they win will be the
ones to certify the presidential
election results in 2024
we got the fake news in full force take
Connie Lee She's a republican candidate
standing for governor she's touted as a
potential running mate for Donald Trump
should he go for the presidency in two
years time but Carrie Lake won't fully
endorse the electoral process Behind
These midterm elections I will
absolutely accept the results of a fair
honest and transparent election 100
percent but your opponents say that you
embody a threat to democracy that raises
many questions not just around these
midterms but for elections to come if
she wins the position of governor and
has influence over this state's
electoral process what does that mean
for the presidential elections in 2024
what does that mean for democracy
here in Washington the Republicans want
control of both houses of Congress
Biden's Democrats desperately need to
hold on to them or he's a lame duck
there are some dramatic and razor-thin
races that could on their own tip the
balance and change everything there's
also the global Dimension to it all
America is seen already as unstable a
deeply diminished Global influencer it
could soon be more fractured more
insular less interested in shaping the
world Beyond and into that space others
China will move
America is at a critical juncture and
that matters to us all